il y aura donc un monstre d'un mètre
vingt de diamètre donc un médecin de
diamètre s'affaissa qui sera positionnée
au milieu avec une hauteur qui sera deux
fois supérieur à la taille des arbres
jean-marc belloir et révolté cet
habitant de noisy le roi se bat avec
plusieurs riverains depuis plus d'un an
contre le projet de l'opérateur free sur
la commune et l'arrivée dans cette forêt
d'un pylône de 34 mètres près du
rond-point du centaure une mesure qui
pourrait avoir un impact sur
l'immobilier ça peut effectivement
stopper des ventes de biens parce que
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
voilà on a nos maisons qui sont
valorisés à tel montant du mètre carré
il faut savoir que lorsque on tournera
la tête tous dans nos jeux depuis le
jardin dans un rayon de 500 mètres et
qu'on verra ce monstre qui va dénaturer
notre village nous craignons aussi une
perte immobilière autre argument avancé
par les riverains la couverture réseau
de ce pilot ne serait pas optimale vu
l'emplacement de ce pylône et de sa
hauteur il va y avoir un très gros écran
avec la forêt tu es sur le côté et les
maisons environnantes
ce qui fait que le quart de noisy sera
invisible pour contrer le projet les
riverains en distribuer les tracts
organiser des manifestations devant la
mairie une requête en annulation a
également été déposé au tribunal
administratif de versailles en juin 2017
si tous les recours sont rejetés les
habitants pourraient aller plus loin
alors si les travaux commencent il faut
savoir qu'il y à une forte mobilisation
citoyenne et il est à craindre
effectivement il y aura certainement des
actions de blocage de chantier vis-à-vis
des engins de chantiers qui pourraient
être opérés par free je le crains nous
on voudrait éviter d'arriver à une telle
extrémité
de son côté la mairie co signataire du
bail ne souhaite pas s'exprimer sur le
sujet pour le moment
un courrier a été envoyé par les élus à
l'opérateur free pour avoir des
précisions sur le dossier